stell dir vor man bestellt essen aber
darf immer nur das teuerste auf der
gesamten Karte bestellen und jetzt hör
auf dieses vorzustellen weil genau das
machen wir heute ich bin hier in Berlin
und wir werden bei drei verschiedenen
Restaurants die wir zufällig auswählen
dass jeweils teuerste Gericht auf der
Karte gestellt und ich konnte mit der
Verwendung von überall heute auf meine
Bestellung 3,15 Cashback bekommen
einfach nur weil ich die drei benutzt
habe los geht's und da sind wir auch
schon wir gehen auf Restaurants und ich
würde sagen ich scroll einfach mal wild
drauflos und macht bei einem beliebigen
Zeitpunkt Stopp also bisschen runter
bisschen hoch ihr kennt den Spaß
mittlerweile es wird einfach nicht alt
und wir haben das erste Restaurant
Tommys burger joint Kudamm 8,0 Sterne
isländische Burger seit 1981 12 90 9,90
€, 13,70 € klassischer Burger und
Süßkartoffel Preis 140 oh hier sind wir
schon bei 16,70 €. das könnte schon
direkt das teuerste sein was es hier im
Shop gibt okay ich gucke mir das noch
mal genau an ja klassischer Burger plus
Süßkartoffel plus Bier muss man dann
halt bestellen ist halt das teuerste auf
der Karte dann gönne ich mir auch mal
ein Bierchen hier rein kurzer Prozess ab
in Warenkorb und wir bestellen beim
ersten Spot weiter geht's zum zweiten
und das wilde scrollen beginnt wieder
ein bisschen runter bisschen hoch die
erste Bestellung ist schon 20 Minuten da
müssen uns ein bisschen beeilen und der
zweites Wort heißt
AC Drop schalottenburg oh es ist nicht
dreckige fort das habe ich in meinem
Berliner Fußball gezeigt jetzt sind
diese unglaublich geilen Brioche Brote
die in der Mitte aufgeschnitten und
gefüllt werden da habe ich auf jeden
Fall Bock drauf ist vielleicht eher so
ein klassisches Frühstück wir haben
jetzt schon Abend aber ist doch egal
schauen wir mal was das teuerste ist
10,90 € ist glaube ich auf den ersten
Blick direkt das teuerste Salomon cheese
Sandwich das ist jetzt so ein Moment wo
ich mir eigentlich wünschen würde was
anderes zu bestellen weil wir haben da
z.B pastrami wir haben Bacon mit Lachs
wird bestimmt auch nicht so verkehrt
sein ist das Räucherlachs ist
Räucherlachs da drauf wir bestellen das
Ding auf jeden Fall mal weil ich bin
gespannt wie die das liefern werden
vielleicht noch ein Drink dazu kommen
macht fertig und wir gehen zum dritten
Spot ein dritter Laden fehlt uns noch
zum vollkommenen Glück und wir schauen
einfach mal was uns jetzt noch erwartet
und unser dritter Laden ist Riesa
chicken jeder Berliner wird es kennen
das ist quasi so ein bisschen so das
Premium KFC von Berlin und ich habe noch
nie dort gegessen auch wenn jeder darauf
schwört und ich könnte mir vorstellen
dass sie wahrscheinlich auch
irgendwelche buckets oder Menüs oder
sowas haben das aber nicht ein bisschen
Angst davor was bei denen das teuerste
auf der Karte ist
Riesa 5 star Menü 6 Nuggets 4 Chili
Wings 4 crispy Filet 2 chicken cross ein
Rieser Burger zwei Toppings ein ganzes
Hähnchen
49,80 €. ich meine das Video ist
eindeutig ne heute gehen wir Riesa
chicken mal gehörig auf den Grund und
bestellen das Rieser five star Menü
jetzt haben wir drei Spots die es
wirklich in sich haben einmal
isländische Burger einmal AC Drop
Sandwich und einmal eine massives
chicken Menü warten wir bis das ganze
ankommt ihr seht in meinen Videos dass
ich viel und häufig bestelle deshalb ist
es eine super Sache dass ich persönlich
die greifen benutze damit ihre kann man
den über 1800 Shops und Geschäften
online Cashback bekommen gerade
heutzutage wo alles teurer wird ist es
echt eine super nice Sache und eine
Besonderheit ihr kriegt mit meinem Link
statt 5 €, 10 € startgut haben und bis
Sonntag sogar 15 €, aber wie
funktioniert die gerade überhaupt ihr
kauft etwas bei Lieferando bei Gold bei
Media Markt oder bucht eine Reise über
booking darüber eine
Vermittlungsprovision und sie von dieser
Provision ein Teil an euch ab mit
anderen Worten eine echte
Win-Win-Situation ihr könnt euch über
die App oder den Browser den jeweiligen
Shop raussuchen dann gelangt ihr mit
einem Klick in den Shop und könnt wie
gewohnt einkaufen außerdem könnt ihr
euch den Cashback Melder als Browser
Erweiterung installieren welcher euch
anzeigt wenn ihr euch auf einem Partner
Shop befindet wo ihr Cashback bekommen
könnt und wenn das der Fall ist könnt
ihr das ganze mit einem Klick aktivieren
Sobald 20 € zusammengekommen sind könnt
ihr das Cashback auf ein PayPal Konto
oder ein Bankkonto überweisen und noch
mal exklusiv kriegt ihr bis Sonntag über
meinen Link statt 5 € Cashback 15 €.
dann ist der Weg zu den 20 € auch gar
nicht mehr so weit also vielen Dank an
die drei klickt auf den ersten Link in
der Videobeschreibung und Sport bei
eurer nächsten Bestellung bares Geld ich
würde sagen wir machen weiter mit dem
Video schauen wir mal was uns erwartet
die erste Bestellung ist da und schauen
wir mal wer am schnellsten war es ist
nicht der Burger sondern das actroops
Sandwich wow erstmal echt schön verpackt
und das Ding wiegt bestimmt 350 400
Gramm das ist eine richtig fetter or
boah guckt euch das mal an alter Schwede
kommt schon dieses source raus okay es
sieht aber nicht ganz so gut aus finde
ich hier auf dem Foto und was eigentlich
bei einem acrop Sandwich soweit ich das
weiß nicht sein sollte das von allen
Seiten geöffnet das heißt auch unten
kommt alles einfach raus innen drin
haben wir eine Scheibe von unserem
Räucherlachs und wir haben auch quasi so
eine bullette von Rührei das so ein
bisschen you vs der Geist
seid mal ehrlich sieht ein bisschen
anders aus ne also wir kennen ja alle
produktfotografieren dann sieht das
besonders gut aus aber es ist jetzt
nicht so krass hübsch wie auf dem Foto
aber nichtsdestotrotz kann es ja sehr
sehr gut schmecken deshalb gehen wir
einfach mal rein wir haben das Endstück
vom Brio bekommen ein bisschen Pech
gehabt
macht schon Sinn warum das eigentlich
geschlossen sein sollte so kommt es halt
einfach unten alles raus und eine
Avocadocreme richtig schön cremig das
Brioche ist sehr sehr schön
erwischt die ganze Zeit nicht das Ei
weil das wieder so runterflutscht aber
ich muss jetzt schon sagen ich habe auf
jeden Fall hier in Berlin bessere
eckdrop Sandwiches gegessen also mit
diesem iPad hier das ist irgendwie so
ein bisschen saß und das hält auch nicht
so geil zusammen es ist sehr brotlastig
definitiv man kriegt was für sein Geld
also du wirst satt von dem Ding schon
mal Pluspunkt es schmeckt auch noch
immer übelst lecker aber bei einem acrop
Sandwich erwarte ich einfach so dieses
noch weichere Brot dazu dann dieses
cremige Rührei ich würde dem ganzen
sieben von zehn geben wobei Sandwich
schnell eine zehn von zehn ist weil es
einfach in der Natur der Sache liegt ich
würde schon noch mal hier bestellen die
nächste Bestellung ist da von Tommy's
burger joint und ich möchte jetzt
herausfinden was in aller Welt ein
isländischer Burger ist ist einfach der
Burger Bräter Isländer oder einmal die
Süßkartoffel Pommes boah die werden ohne
Soße geliefert irgendwie ein bisschen
schade und dazu der isländische Burger
eine Pommes ist noch drin die werden wir
nicht
verstanden wow die Pommes sind sehr sehr
krass ich habe gerade gesehen dass der
Laden einfach nur 300 Meter weiter ist
normal knusprig und jetzt gucken wir uns
mal den isländischen Burger an
Alter ist Isländisch das neue Synonym
für traurig sie sieht ja wirklich
einfach nur traurig aus alter sieht ja
wirklich mega traurig aus aber eine
Scheibe Salat eine Scheibe Tomate dann
dieses Patty aber warte mal oben auf dem
Deckel ist ein bisschen Maja und
burgersoße okay immerhin aber probieren
wir das Ganze aber uns besser beurteilen
zu können
dann ist gut ich hatte kurz ein bisschen
Schiss dass das so ein tiefkühlburger
ist hat auf jeden Fall schöne
Grillaromen das war's dann aber auch
also dieser Burger macht mich ein
bisschen traurig er schmeckt trotzdem
irgendwie gut ne das ist aber mehr so
ein frikadellenbrötchen als ein Burger
weil sie hat nicht so dieses geile
matschige ich weiß aber wirklich noch
mal herausfinden warum dieser Burger
Isländisch ist man findet auch nicht
wenn man isländische Burger eingibt
findet man auch nichts ich habe jetzt
halt auch ein super Standard Burger
bestellt ne die haben auch
wahrscheinlich andere mit Soßen ist auf
jeden Fall sehr sehr puristisch trifft
nicht ganz mein Burger Geschmack ist für
mich einfach ein bisschen zu wenig was
abgeht das Fleisch schmeckt aber gut und
hat auch eine merklich gute Qualität
gibt den Burger eine sechs von zehn was
wird denn jetzt zu einer fünf von zehn
oder vier von zehn machen klare Sache
irgendwie gekauftes sesambahn so ein
Standard Band oder ein tiefkühlpatty
aber vor allem fehlt mir Soße mir fehlt
Soße mir fehlt Käse aber
es ist halt ich essen trotzdem auf alter
Schwede die dritte Bestellung ist da und
die wiegt ungelogen
zweieinhalb Kilo wir haben einfach eine
Packung Brot mittendrin ich packe das
alles jetzt erstmal aus und dann gucken
wir uns mal auf dem Tisch an alter
Schwede also value for money ist auf
jeden Fall krass weil 50 €. ich glaube
davon können auch 50 Leute essen hier
knüpft uns das jetzt mal Step by Step
vor
zum Glück habe ich viel Hunger und
Philipp hinter der Kamera auch wir
werden das alles verputzen gucken wir
mal die erste Box rein die ist alleine
schon unfassbar schwer und darin boah
haben wir verschiedene chicken pieces
die Chicken piece sehen auf jeden Fall
geil paniert aus ich habe jemanden drum
und ich probiere das jetzt
richtig richtig soft Crunch von der
Panade ist immer noch da das Chicken ist
richtig schön Lucy und das ist auf jeden
Fall was anderes
ohne Knochen
es hat ein geile Spice Mix auf jeden
Fall in der Panade eine leichte Schärfe
wahrscheinlich auch 11 geheimes weißes
krass was ist jetzt aber in den anderen
schicken Boxen drin eine Mischung aus
Ofenkartoffeln Süßkartoffel Preis unten
nochmal einen Pommes auch das hier ist
wirklich wieder so unfassbar viel essen
ich glaube wir werden morgen auch noch
chicken frühstücken bisschen unter der
Lieferung gelitten sehr sehr matschig
leider nicht so geil weiter geht's hier
ist relativ wenig drin deshalb bin ich
umso gespannt da das ist der Riesa ich
habe gesagt
Mann ich packen wir aus wir haben hier
einfach so zwei oder drei Bohnen des
pieces auf dem sesamann mit ein bisschen
Salat und ich denke mal einfach Mario
ist keine Erleuchtung der Burger aber
geschockt hat mich bisher vor allem das
Chicken wir sind noch immer nicht am
Ende die haben wir Nuggets in der Box
die sehen wirklich einfach komplett aus
wie Meckes Nuggets sind aber nicht ganz
so
krasser haben wir noch
[Musik]
denn hier drin ist wenn mich nicht alles
täuscht ein ganzes Hähnchen auf einem
Fladenbrot also jetzt ist es wirklich
vorbei das ist für eine ganze Familie
ich will unbedingt aber noch hier den
Mais probieren geil irgendwie in so
einer Tüte
geil der meist richtig lecker schönen
saftig süß meist ist einfach durch eine
krasse Kombination mit schicken unterm
Strich ist das ein Berliner Tag auf KFC
richtig geschockt haben mich zwei Sachen
und zwar die Chicken peaces und das
Preis-Leistungsverhältnis weil man ist
hier mit 49 Euro wirst du wirklich mit
einer ganzen Familie fünf Leute werden
easy satt deshalb alles in allem auch
wenn es das teuerste auf der Karte war
ich würde eine acht von zehn geben auf
jeden Fall die höchste Bewertung heute
lasst mich euch eins sagen wir werden
dieses chicken jetzt angreifen und wie
gesagt dafür Sorge tragen dass nichts
weggeworfen wird vielen Dank fürs
zuschauen vielen Dank klickt auf den
ersten Link in der Videobeschreibung und
spart bei eurer nächsten Bestellung
bares Geld Berlin hat mich nicht ganz
überzeugt Leute geile Auswahl aber nicht
immer geile Ausführung ja wir sehen uns
beim nächsten wieder macht's gut bis
dahin und ciao